je crois que la secrétaire d'état
chargée du droit des femmes à main n'a
pas été très maladroite elle a lancé ça
d'ailleurs elle a été reprise par gérard
collomb par d'autres membres du
gouvernement
si on veut faire évoluer la société il
faut le faire là encore dans le dialogue
et la conviction vous vous n'êtes pas
fermé sur cette extension de la firme à
des fins plus de 10 ce terminal mais sur
ses déclarations
mais je pense que la manière dont cette
annonce est un peu maladroitement était
une erreur d'un ministre débutants qui
n'a pas rendu service à sa cause en le
faisant ainsi vous vous êtes c'est votre
cause l'endosser cette course c'est pas
ma cause mes rêves je suis prêt à
l'accepter au nom d' évolution de notre
société